what's up guys I figured I'd share the I
guess the journey of getting started in
Ruby on Rails and becoming kind of an a
novice developer front-end developer
designer a lot of businesses and
companies already are using it a lot
started with it
Twitter for instance or github was on
Ruby on Rails for a long time the same
is true for Shopify stuff like that is
all written in Ruby and Ruby is a really
approachable language from a beginner
developer so I really enjoy the
cleanliness of it I guess compared to
something like PHP or JavaScript
it's definitely almost magic how things
work but they work really well so this
is just an introduction to that and I
wanted to kind of invite you on board
following along the next part of this
will be kind of getting familiar with
what you need to run Ruby on Rails on
your system depending on if it's a Mac
or PC I'll kind of walk through at least
the Mac portion and that's what I
primarily develop on
the biggest and probably the most
hardest step to getting started with
Ruby on Rails is actually installing it
if you're on a Mac changes are you have
Ruby already installed on your system
but to get started on installing rails
it's a good practice they kind of follow
a guide there's one that I I would say
is probably that most up-to-date called
install rails on install rails comm it's
brought to you by the people from one
month to start let's go ahead and just
dive in assuming you're on a Mac you can
follow along with me if you're on a PC
there are alternative steps to take and
it will actually tell you which way to
to go here so on a Mac you'll want to
actually make sure your versions at
least up to these current versions 10.6
is pretty old I'm using the latest Mac
Book Pro I do have Xcode installed you
don't necessarily need the whole Xcode
app if you want to install just the
command-line tools you can do that too I
think I have Xcode what was it
I can't remember the actual key command
right now but I have it installed the
easiest way to do it just go to the App
Store install Xcode you need the
command-line tools to do a lot of things
that we'll need to utilize in the coming
steps going forward here is talking
about the command-line and you can use
the built-in one I like to use one
called hyper it's at hyper dot is I
think hyper is yeah and it's based on
j/s HTML and CSS
I used to use I term too but this one
just kind of has been on my radar so you
can use whatever you want and going back
to this guide you can open your terminal
and it's just kind of giving you a quick
run-through of a this is what a terminal
can do a big big thing on you like
utilizes homebrew I actually have it
installed if you want to install it you
can head to home Bruce page or there's a
the scripture you can run here if we run
Bru V I should get homebrew one point
three point four is my current one
there's a key command run called brew
doctor might as well run it just kind of
checks everything out and make sure it's
up to spec will run that real quick cool
so by the way I'm working in a directory
just on my desktop called sites I just
created that right before the screencast
so nothing nothing special there
git is obviously important it's a
version control software basically you
can create snapshots of your code and
later reference them if you need to and
or create branches that are different
features
so branches are such saying hey clone
this app and I want to do this to it but
keep that other other screenshot the way
it was so I think I'd get installed that
I want to I might as well check first
so we'll do get I do it alright so a two
point fourteen point one I think is my
latest if you're new to get and you're
just just installing it for the first
time you do need to create global user
parameters and get is not same as github
so don't don't miss can skew those it's
actually something that stays local but
you can add github as a remote thing
that you can push your local stuff up to
I'm already set up so I won't go through
all that installing Ruby you can do
globally just like anything else but
it's very very I guess advised to use a
ruby version manager and that's what
actually our VM is in this case I tend
to use one called our B and V I'm just
used saying that for short it's the same
thing it's just kind of done differently
so we can install the latest see what
versions we got two point four point two
so let's go ahead and do that so if I do
RB and B it's hard to remember install
two point four point two
cool so we're at this moment downloading
Ruby 2 point four point two this takes a
bit so I'll probably speed this part of
the video up but just make sure you do
this step because you don't want to use
the system based Ruby version it's too
outdated for rails five point one point
seven or whatever it is now I said I put
one point four so while that downloads
I'll speed this video up this finally
installed two point two to our versions
on our our B&B directory inside my
actual user directory so we if we do our
B I'm probably saying this wrong but
that's just how I say at the fitti
versions it should show two now and what
we want to do is set that to point four
two at this point so what you'll type is
our B&B global two point four point two
and then we'll do one more time I'm
hitting the up key to bring back the
history there are B inversions and it's
set so we're all square on the Ruby
front cool
all right next to get rails to work we
need to actually install it so you're
going to sell it with the actual Jim and
Ruby gems are similar to something like
NPM if you have ever used node it's it's
basically the same thing I would say
node copied off of the Jim library if
you google Ruby gems it should I think I
have that URL wrong maybe James there's
a whole site dedicated to these and
they're basically like these awesome
plugins there's plenty of potential out
there to go ahead and build an app of
your wildest dreams
so with that rails is actually one of
them so you can making google rails and
you'll see it here it's five point one
point four it's the latest if you just
want to add this to your product you can
do it like this it goes into this file
called a gem file which we'll get into
just just install it verbatim you can do
it like this the guide here is actually
kind of cool it's it's basically
installing rails without some stuff we
really don't need like documentation and
stuff like that so I'm gonna go ahead
and do the same on our installation just
paste that into the terminal and hit
enter
all right as you can see 37 Jim's had
installed 4 rails to kind of work we can
check if rails is indeed working if we
go to Rails version so I have rails 5.1
0.4 installed at this time if you run
into issues definitely look at look into
this stuff if you're following along and
using the same and Ruby manager as me
there's a lot of documentation here
definitely recommend homebrew if you're
not using it it will make your life
easier if you do on a Mac for sure at
this point we've got rails going
we've got Ruby installed and then the
next step let's see just install code
editor and we can create our first app
this is gonna be me walking you through
how to create a simple blog like
structure using Ruby on Rails as the I
guess the CMS and the actual creation
edit and deletion of posts of a typical
blog I'm using such things as like boma
which is a CSS framework you see all
these Styles are kind of adapted from it
but this is the basic app we'll be
building and is you can create posts
read posts and actually comment on posts
too so here's that what a post could
look like and this is all without any
kind of user accounts so in future
lessons or videos I'll be actually
creating a user admin kind of side of
this so where if you were an admin user
you'd have say these controls but if you
weren't you wouldn't see that at all so
we'll be going deeper into that and
future stuff so stay tuned for that but
this is just kind of to get you started
with rails and Ruby and to get your
palate adjusted to how things work with
with it it's a little I guess hard at
first to understand if you're new to
Ruby and rails but essentially we're
working with a MVC pattern on this web
app framework known as Ruby on Rails of
course this I have running this is what
you'll be building it's the demo app
which is on github and I'll share that
in the link or the description etc so
when we get to that point this will be
what we make we're going to probably do
some copy and pasting in the sense of
styling and maybe some HTML markup just
because it's going to save you save you
some time and the point of this series
is to just learn Ruby on Rails so
without further ado I'll go ahead and
get started
I have this server running our demo app
already and it kind of looks like this
in my terminal I'm gonna go to control C
out of that and it's called on github
demo blog rails and I did kind of a
one-pager of what we're actually doing
here so it's a like I said it's a blog
to demonstrate Ruby on Rails with posts
and comments
so the main features will be obviously
posts and comments for the comments will
actually do that it's gonna be create
read update destroy or a crud pattern
for posts and then comments it'll be
create read and destroy so if you alter
a comment you can see it obviously but
user can also delete it but they can't
edit it there are these things known as
gems and Ruby on Rails
and these act as kind of like a node
package manager kind of scenario very
very similar but will make be making use
of these as I go through and these are
basically out of preference for myself
but also just stuff that is a time saver
later on there's thing known as guard
that helps with tons of tasks behind the
scenes if you used to like grunt or gulp
or something like that it kind of works
like that but we'll use live reload for
our sass and any changes through our J s
or E or B files otherwise known as HTML
files in this case and then there's a
better edge errors Jim and one called
simple form which makes authoring forms
and rails pretty darn easy so this will
all be accompanied with a blog post so
definitely you know look to that for
these code snippets but also this is all
in github so I'm gonna back out of this
project the demo app and actually create
a new one we'll just call it demo blog
so I'm gonna do rails well let me make
sure there's not one in there yeah I do
rails new demo blog and I should
generate everything we need there and
run bundle which will install all of our
gems
so with that installed we can go ahead
and CD into that demo blog directory LS
yeah so those are all the files and
folders in our directory by default git
is initialized so that's pretty cool
if you want to go ahead and version this
definitely start now everything that is
ignored should be ignored but you can
also ignore more files if you want to
that's just how it comes out of the box
I probably will just go ahead and do
that just to make things I'll just run
getting it and get and so get commits
and commit cool all right and then I'm
clearing that using command K if you're
new to the command line you can also
type clear and hit enter and it'll do
the same
okay so first what we need to do is
verify our apps running so we can just
use rails server and this is a good
practice just in case your environments
not instead of correctly or something's
off this is going to go away and turn
into this which is the screen you should
see if you installed rails correctly all
right so with rails installed we need to
get our you know mindset around this app
and how it works there are things we
need to configure that make the routing
work right and to get to get things
kicked off and when actually generate it
what is known a controller so I'm going
to keep this server running and I'm
actually going to create a new tab in my
terminal community and hyper I think
it's the same in I term and probably
your default terminal app if you're on a
Mac of course so I'm gonna have an alias
set up for that sites directory which is
just my desktop sites cool
you need to CD into our actual app again
so demo blog and here I'm going to
actually want to install the gems we
want first I think that's a good
starting point so let me open this in
sublime here we go and I have the actual
blog that I showed you first behind it
someone it minimize that because we
might reference it later just for some
quick HTML stuff that we used which you
can basically just grab from the bowl my
website which I'll get into so by
default it seems
huge if you can see it these are the
gyms that install with rails most of
them I mean you make use of SAS rails of
course Puma is required a sequel light
is definitely required for your database
you can make that any other type of
database if you want we'll get into that
in future videos and of course rails
again I talked about this in a few video
a while back so definitely check that
out but what we want to install are
these gems that basically make our life
easier when working with rails I'm gonna
reference a file real quick one for sure
is called better heirs and we'll
actually do that I mean it could be in
the development group I guess but I'm
going to put it here just for now so
we'll do the gem better heirs I'm
referencing a file what you should do
isn't this and just type it in because
it's pain but I'll show you what I end
up doing less the time to four okay so
we have better errors okay cool so
that's obviously you can come in here
and just say make errors that are
looking just by default in rails if you
get an error it's this big ugly mess of
red stuff red Fonz Fred Phil's and stuff
I got better errors just looks better it
gives you a little more data of what's
going on and ice that should be Jim okay
so you may be wondering okay I'm never
going to remember you know this why I'm
never going to you know figure out where
that's gonna be so there's a site called
Ruby gems which conveniently enough our
gem file actually references if you look
at the very top and go to it here
it's source is from rubygems.org so
definitely a good site to you know keep
in your back pocket so we'll go to that
site and as you work with rails you
start to find gems that you're kind of
you're just your go-to so don't think
you're gonna you're supposed to know
these elf hands but as you see in other
apps they could just kind of come
throughout when working with it so
here's the best place to find the most
updated region or version sorry
definitely recommend doing it the gem
file method and not install on your
system because then you're stuck with it
on your system and this is more of a gem
file per project approach so your
projects will vary based on what you're
building so definitely keep that in mind
so I'm just going to go ahead and paste
that in just for safety's sake the next
one I want to use is called boma so I'm
gonna do a search for OMA and I always
look to kind of see which one has the
most downloads usually that's the best
candidate somebody ain't copy that go
back to our gem file at it we'll call it
Roma CSS and bomas like a lean down
modern bootstrap kind of CSS framework I
like it you don't have to use it you can
use bootstrap you can use foundation
whatever you want simple form is our
next one so I'm gonna go to
and in most cases you're probably gonna
install these not all at once and have
your mind made up already but for the
sake of this tutorial I'm gonna go ahead
and install them all it's probably best
to install each as you work forward
instead of just all at once so the next
ones are going to be guard and guard
live reload there's some quite some
configuration with this one it's kind of
hard to understand at first but they do
have repos that you can reference for
the how to's and on rubygems if you go
to the home page or the source code
typically it's you know the best place
to go the github repos tend to be the
most up-to-date so I definitely refer to
those and this is guards for example so
will actually put that this one's kind
of special we only need it in our
development environment so rails has a
specific group that classifies that as
the environment here and we'll actually
put that in there and you don't need to
add these comments at all but typically
up just from my own you know sake I'll
copy kind of the one-liner that they
give it rubygems.org and throw it in
there and then the main reason we need
guard is this guard live reload
extension that's what I primarily use it
for guard is capable so much more so
don't let me you know sway you and
thinking that it's just for this guard
live reload search for that hmm there it
is someone I install that
and I'll do the same thing with the
description all right so we've got our I
think all the necessary gems that I need
for this particular project installed
gems are kind of be gonna be your Savior
in a lot of cases as just come to find
things like user user accounts user
roles there are so many out there that
are great for handling that stuff for
you
I definitely google that stuff just kind
of get familiar with the process and
we'll we'll definitely touch on those
more in future videos so stay tuned of
course next since we have those gems
installed we need to run this thing
called bundle which actually goes out
and fetches that data for each so we're
gonna install everything we just added
and you'll start to see those names now
over here like simple form let's see
guard should be there yeah so you'll see
them now that's part of a dependency in
the project now so that's great when I
do that I tend to kind of restart my
server so if you do control C on a Mac
you can just kill your server and then
run real server again okay so for our
some of our gems there is some setup
required I'm gonna go to the simple form
one and do that one real quick and I'll
never remember how this should be but if
you refer to the repo like I said that's
the best place to figure out how to do
this setup it gives you kind of the idea
here but like I said this gym isn't up
to date I mean it would fetch the latest
version but in your project you might
need to specific version so that's why
rubygems.org is the thing so definitely
use it instead of these repos
so we need to run this generator for
this to work for this specific gym this
is the simple form Jim and I'm gonna
actually go to my other tab on my
terminal I'm in that actually let's do a
git and
and Jim's simple is that okay so we need
to next run that generator which is
rails Derner neat simple form install
and that's I just literally copied and
pasted from that repo if you are using
bootstrap or foundation it comes out of
the box with support for those so up to
you if you want to
I'm going to show you how to use this
CSS framework called bulma and it is
essentially more or less a modern for
take on bootstrap or stuff like that
it's got a really cool style look and
feel to it so I just figured I'd give it
a shot it's actually my first warmth
more or less my first time using its
others there might be some googling and
stuff that I'll have to do to figure
some stuff out in terms of class names
but definitely check it out it's based
on flexbox which is nice that installed
we can go ahead and bypass these flags
to install bootstrap in foundation we
don't need those we'll run the generator
to simple form install and it should do
its thing cool and it just gives you a
kind of a feedback saying hey you can
rerun this if you want to use bootstrap
or foundation it's the same same thing I
just told you so
we really should be all set there's no
migrations to run or anything here so
that's great next we want to configure a
guard and I'm actually got the write-up
of how to do it if you go to that ruby
gem site and then go to guard live
reload you can link to this it'll show
you what to do
we actually need to just notice I need
to add this require false on that gym
file you do right there and I'm gonna
actually turn on word rep actually need
to run bundle one more time you're gonna
find yourself doing this a lot okay and
for safety
we can we can do this again if you just
hit the up-arrow rails s again great
running you can verify it in the browser
we're good okay one thing to get guard
live reload initialized is to create
what is known as a guard file and that's
part of using garden and I should
preface all this and say you don't need
to use this stuff it's just useful if
you want your browser to refresh
automatically when you do style changes
or something like that
you can configure it to do more based on
whatever file types you use like Hamill
slim J s EML etc so it's pretty useful
in that regard so one thing we need to
run after that gym is installed and
configured as shown here is garden it
library loaded and it might throw some
warnings at you it's okay basically all
it did is create a guard file with some
specs in it so we'll go back to our
project and you'll see this new file
called guard file so it should be
actually set up out of the box so that's
great this stuff I know it looks
confusing but it's basically just it's
finding directories in your project and
watching them as they change so there's
some kind of what's it called I forget
now but specific keys and file names and
structure and stuff like that to watch
and update your project as you save
basically so with that I'll set up one
more thing we need to do is make sure
you have the actual browser in its
extension installed if you go to live
reload comms less extensions it'll give
you links to each I'm using Chrome so
actually install this in the web store I
think all right so I already have live
reload installed so no need to do it on
my end if you don't go ahead and install
this extension I believe it's available
for almost all browsers so it will make
your life awesome when you actually
install it and use it in Ruby on Rails
so switch over to our terminal and with
everything
essentially okay we should be able to
run bundle exec garden and that specific
command is there because we need our
dependencies if you don't run it with
bundle exec in front it won't notice
that you're using certain dependencies
so it's kind of a long thing to remember
but Gard is essentially the command line
Keith's key term that fires things off
when you're using garden but in our case
we need to run it as is and it'll just
kind of do its thing so once you run it
once it just sits there and waits for
stuff to change so at this point we can
you know make a new terminal window
again and go back into our site's
directory and then go back to our demo
and you know go to town so at this point
we should have everything installed and
we can verify that by first creating our
very first controller so I'm going to go
ahead and do that and we get this out of
the way since we're using a blog I'm
going to do a posts controller so to do
that we need to generate G or you can
type generate here - controller and if
you're very very new to this and want to
figure out what this stuff actually does
you can do the flag help when you do
generate controller and rails will spit
out kind of what you can do what you can
configure on the fly there are options
to skip things if you don't want them to
be generated like JavaScript or the
assets at all you can use a certain
template engine and not use the default
er B so that's kind of useful but yeah
so read into that if you just type the
flag help after a lot of things it will
give you a lot of insight that it wasn't
so you know I guess understandable by me
at first but until I read that stuff it
made more sense so let's just do this
rails generate controller second spell
controller and we'll actually call this
I'm gonna do capital I'm going to call
it on
hoes it should be plural for the
controller so for your models which
we'll get into keep those singular just
remember that so by default you can you
can have what actions could be on this
like index show edit create etc I'm
gonna go ahead and just leave them off
for now because we'll actually type
those in so I can show you exactly how
this stuff works so we'll just do it the
basic generation of posts and as you can
see in the controllers it will generate
this file called pulse post controller
RB and various the view posts folder the
test stuff helper stuff assets like I
said you can flag this stuff to not
generate I attend to just you know run
with a flow and and just generate it and
delete it later that's just me being
lazy of course so alright so let's again
open this and sublime so in our app
directory we're gonna find our new post
controller and this is all generated by
default so to show proof of concept I'm
going to create action called index and
one more thing to get this to work is to
create a view called index so you go
into your views folder your posts folder
and then create index dot HTML dot RB
but for now I'll do it with just h1 I
think they use class title and then we
could just put index log index
so finally if if you were to visit the
site okay it's still working and you can
go to posts and then you'll see that but
we actually need a route first so that's
why we're getting Aires and I know this
bundle my better Aires gym isn't working
so that's interesting
all right guys I can't get for some
reason this better Aires gym isn't
working for me but it should look like
this on their repo and I it's kind of
mind-boggling but what I did though try
I mistakenly added it to the basic gym
repo but we needed it in our development
environment so I put it down here for
now so if it were to work go ahead and
put it there make sure you do because
you don't want that in production so
anyway it's okay if we don't have it but
that should be working it might work for
you and it just isn't for me at this
moment so okay so we're still getting
this air that when we access the posts
controller we made there's nothing there
and that's because there is no routes
set up so we actually need to set that
up in our routes config file so go to
the config folder routes and then we'll
just do this thing called resources and
then posts and that should be it but to
make things a little easier so we don't
to navigate to slash posts in the URL
I'm going to go ahead and put a route
parameter and change that to index or
posts index
okay now that should do it when you do
update your routes file you you probably
want to restart your server yet again so
go do rails s and go back to that
refresh and there we go we got our blog
index and that should be all set
alright guys I took some time and got
this stuff working so never fear on your
end it should work if everything's set
up correctly of course but I got the
better Aires thing to working and to
just prove it I went to a post that
didn't exist so it's working there
and then I noticed when I went to my
post index I was like wondering why my
CSS wasn't loading and that's because I
was getting ahead of myself and the bull
my gym requires you to import the boma
styles stylesheet in your application
CSS so I'm gonna go to Ruby gems and go
to that home page real quick just to
show you by example so Bulma and Bulma
rails and go to the home page it should
take you to a github page and the main
thing I forgot is when you import it you
need to actually import it into the main
stylesheet of the project so I'm gonna
go do that and we're gonna use sass by
default it's gonna be a CSS file and
your style sheets go ahead and rename
that to s CSS and you should be able to
use sass right out-of-the-box so there
we go and I'm gonna just import that
bulma CSS there I think we have guard
running now we need to so bundle exec
garden
okay so if I save that again which it's
not really I set this as sin thanks
let's do CSS I guess I don't have sass
for it for some reason that's great okay
so back to our blog watch the type
hopefully update here give it a second
there it goes okay great so we know
basically verifying that our CSS is
loading okay so now that we have our
initial in index action created and our
view index created we know that things
are working we've got our routes set up
in our config file if you go to come fig
routes RB and you should have these
things in here so great we're ready to
get rolling so what we want to do is
kind of configure the actual way this is
going to work so there are other actions
we'll need to include on our controller
but the main one I want to start with is
they create action but we need a form to
create a blog post right so let's go
ahead and do that and first to do create
we actually need this action called new
and then create okay and we actually
need some data to work with here so this
is where models come in and I'm gonna
actually generate one right now called
post so let's go back and make a new tab
and go to my sites again see demo blog
great and I'll actually do rails
generate model
and call it post capitalized and I'm
gonna give it these basically what I
call them data types and it's just
basically the things that get entered
into the database and you can name them
but you also have to tell the database
what kind of data type it is so in this
case for a blog post I want a title and
it's going to be a string type of data
and we also probably have you know
content within that blog post so I'm
going to do text some text is it like a
long-form text so think of it like that
so you can add as many as you want
to a model like this but you can also
pin things later with these things known
as migrations which we'll get into let
me bump up the size if you're having
trouble there and when running this it
generates our model so let's go and do
that okay so you'll see it created a
migration in itself that's part of the
model process so in this if you want to
see what a migration looks like you can
go to your project and there is this
file call or this folder called DB
inside of it's a migration folder and
inside of that as the migration we just
created rails is pretty smart by default
it does the time stamping so you don't
have to worry about dates and stuff like
that or like you know created at kind of
stuff that's already included by default
on pretty much any model or migration
and here's those things we entered as
the tables in this sense at that point
we can run what is known as rake DB
migrate or rails DB my grade and that
will set that up in the database for
good and you can roll this back well
hopefully I don't have to do that in
this video but we'll get into that later
on if you need to so forget sake I'm
gonna end
oops message add post model okay so at
this point we can we should be able to
interact with that model itself we need
to basically add it to our controller in
such a way that we interact with the
model so you'll see in our app directory
we have the model post created shouldn't
have to do anything at this point we
will later when we add comments to this
thing so don't worry about worry about
that for now but we will interact there
but then our main source of work right
now comes to this controller the post
controller so let's go ahead and we can
reference this post by doing that and
essentially we're calling that post
model now and we can say hey we want a
new one the creative method utilizes the
new route so if you are confused about
routing since we added that resources
parameter to our config file or a routes
file should say if you run rake routes
it'll spit back all the basic crud
actions for the post controller so we
have post index which is like the index
page of the blog create which would be
where you would go to create or the
action that takes place when you create
a blog post new is the actually path you
take to go create edit of course as to
edit show is to just view the individual
blog post update is to edit it it does
kind of that you can do different types
of updation updation has that word
updating and then of course you can
delete it so that's kind of explaining
that at any time if you run rake routes
rails will spit back all of your routes
in your routes file and kind of the URI
pattern and the action involved so it's
super super helpful so going back to our
project that kind of gives you the sense
of what these actions are and where
you're going to be going when you create
a new post
something of that nature when we create
a new post we actually need to do post
and do a similar fashion post new but we
need to pass in the parameters that we
used to create the posts and you could
pass those in right in line like this
but you're gonna find that you're gonna
be reusing this in other actions so
there's this private method you can add
to your controller file that allows you
to create this thing post params and if
this isn't making sense that's okay I
was lost
when I first started this but the more
you do it the more it makes sense so
here we're requiring for our model these
specific records or tables whatever we
generated in that migration and this is
kind of a security feature of rails that
only permits these things from being
actually input to the form we do when we
create this record if they aren't
initialized here you can't actually
submit data to the server so that's kind
of a security thing so what we're really
doing in this case is passing this
function into this new creation method
here and then we can check to see if
that post saved and then if it did we'll
want to redirect to the post itself else
render the new template again okay so at
basic form we're ready to create a new
post in this sense if we go to run rails
new we're going to get an error so
because I don't have the template yet so
it needs a template in our views folder
so if we go back to our views go to
posts new file new HTML Arabi
and we could just for now I'll just do
so that should at least load the page
now great to create the form we need we
are actually going to I'm gonna copy I'm
referencing another screen right now but
I'm gonna add some markup that we need
for boma plus our form so let me do this
real quick might speed this up so you
guys aren't bored before I do though
this is where we're getting that simple
form gym going and essentially rails has
a built in form builder it's just almost
just like this but simple form kind of
obviously simplifies the process so it's
it's one that I find pretty useful and
makes more sense for stuff I do you're
welcome to use the rails way they
there's does tons of stuff too
so it's it's just a matter of preference
I would say so so I had to experiment
with bulma to get this to work and I had
to do a little extra code outside of
simple form the whole intent of simple
form is to eliminate I think the amount
of markup you have to provide I'll to
walk you through this stuff in a second
wrapper false label just you know
class label so that's one input field
and that's going to be for our title and
the way this works is you reference the
actual record here of the input and that
rails are smart enough and simple form
is smart enough to know what that means
here we're classifying actual class on
the input field itself and we need to
input in this case for Bulma we don't
want the rapper by default simple form
puts its own wrapper around the input
field and this was causing errors with
boma because it had a similar class so
there was clashing of styles and I
didn't want that so in simple form you
can put a wrapper false declaration and
that will help and then our label HTML
we needed a class of labels so I went
ahead and added that too so this is one
field in the sense for our form I'm
going to create a copy of that and paste
it down and this one's gonna be for a
Content and we actually want this to
have a class of text area according to
bulma and label HTML we should be set
there then the last thing we need is our
button to submit the form of course so
I've got button and then submit and this
is built into simple forms that's
nothing we created always put great new
post oops in class
button is primary that's part of Bulma
as well so if all works
you should have our style set up yeah
there we go so that took some trial and
error but I got it to make basically
work for us so that was pretty nifty at
the time yeah and once we'll get into
cleaning this up in a second in terms of
making this look like our first app I
showed you at the beginning but let's
verify this works test post content
should get an error I think yeah so
there's no show method right now or
action on our controller and we actually
need to have that so let's set that up
so I'll go back to my post controller
and we need to create an actual show
action def show and in line and on the
show we actually we need to find the
post that was created so if you do post
dot to find params ID so we're finding
by the ID and we'll be reusing this line
about three more times so at the end
I'll show you a way to kind of make use
of before filter or action that allows
you just to kind of have that set in
stone you only need to write the code
once just kind of a really dry of
approach but for now just to show you
how things work this is what we need so
in that sense if we head back should
find that we need now and I'll show
template so let's go to our posts folder
again create a new file called showed
HTML that Irby and we can just I don't
know what did I have in my markup here
quite a bit of stuff so I just do
section
I don't know if I have I'd you okay
great teener for now I'll just put the
title and the content and rails if
you're new to it this is kind of the
general way it looks so you can do Ruby
inside these brackets and percent signs
if you want to echo it out but the equal
sign if you don't and you want to just
perform some operation or set of their
variable you can do that there you don't
want to do too much magic inside those
it's more more so for just displaying
the data so keep that in mind so here we
have reference to that post symbol and
we can just target the title that we
created so I'll just create a class I
think ball my house when we call content
and I can do the same with the content
type so the controller sending this data
through to the view if you can think of
that that's how we have access to this
post property or symbol as they call
them and that is shown here so fall goes
right we should be able to see that data
there it is so and that gives itself an
ID if we go back to our posts index will
see the index let's let's clean this up
a little bit so our index we can do this
section as well like to see section
section then I have container
and that'sthat's basically a max width
and boundary for our project I created
for Bulma I created these it looks like
a cards on the front end so I'll go
ahead go through this with you for our
index we actually do need to set a new
variable or symbol on our project where
it gets all the posts so I actually want
this to be plural
instead of post in this case so we'll go
post all and then order here you can
just establish how it's displayed I
think about when you do loop through all
the posts so order descending and notice
in Ruby you don't need ugly semicolons
and all that stuff so I really like it
it's really clean so going back here now
we have access to that posts symbol so
we'll go ahead and reference it and
notice I'm not outputting this loop I'm
actually creating what is a rails loop
at this point but with you dot each do
post
I said rails it's a ruby loop excuse me
and then we can loop through each post
so the boma way goes like this at least
the style I chose so bear with me
you
okay so with the markup in place that
should do it for us we need to add
support for the post title and to do
that go back and do post title I notice
here since we were looping through we
don't need this to write the symbol with
the @ sign in front of it we're using
this as the variable throughout so
something to keep in mind when you do
loop through things so it's just post
our content post a title and comments we
will add later from for now they'll be
see if I can just comment that out
comment the comment firmament at each no
I did that wrong it should be posts boom
alright so there's our first post great
going one step further obviously I can't
click that post right now and want to
click it to go to the actual individual
post so to do that instead of just the
title here we'll make use of that but we
want to do a link to in rails which is a
handy basically hrf generator with a ton
of properties and then we'll actually
link to the post itself and again this
is one of those rake routes situations
if you're not sure what a link to this
is you know where I got that from so
here now it's a link we can link to the
post great alright so I think next I'm
gonna add general links to you know kind
of navigate this blog a little easier so
I'm gonna actually pull up my other
project and get the layout file open and
the layout file is kind of the global
source of truth for your Styles this is
where all your content gets fed through
this yield sign is everything we've been
creating so far all this stuff gets fed
into that and spit out so I want to
actually add this content to our layout
and I'll talk you through it
and this is this kind of a time-saver so
don't think you need to learn every bit
that I'm teaching you here but let's see
so most of this is boma and here I've
created a section class called hero if
you go to the Bowlin library there's a
whole section on that let's see here oh
and there's different snippets you can
use I use one that's basically let me
find it I think it was this one here but
I eliminated this bottom row of Link's
because we only need really one or so in
this project so let me go back and show
you how that worked we have our hero
section the hero head the navbar itself
in it I didn't create a logo or anything
it's just text that says demo blog and
we're using a link to function we just
use in rails and linking to our root
path you notice the path extension
doesn't come when you rake routes but
that's just kind of an understood path
that you can pull from each route so we
can get posts paths or new post paths or
edit post paths that's something that
you just kind of learn as you go it's
not so obvious sadly so let me go back
to the project and we're giving it a
class and have our item for the sake of
FOMA
and then we added a link on the end of
the nav on the right side which will
link to a new post path as again adding
that path at the end and that will allow
us to go to that new URL path and then
here I'm doing something nifty where you
can actually for each of your views you
can specify something in your layout
file using this thing called content for
and I'll show you how that works right
now so essentially you can set the
variable here but define it in your
views so when you hit that view in your
URL path that updates based on whatever
you said so to make that make more sense
I'll do this one right so it'd be
it's called content four and then I set
it as page title in our layout file and
this one I just want to call index so if
we head to our index page you should see
that new layout form and then our index
thing is set or index title and going
back to the layout once more
it's called page title so on each of our
view is well actually need to add
something of this nature so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that for all of you so far
new create new posts if you don't add
this it will air out so it will pretty
pretty obvious what views you don't have
it on okay so with this set up when you
know create new posts and that we just
set and then we'll actually need to do
it on the show view as well but this in
this case we need to actually have a
variable set for it so let me copy that
back and you don't have to use a string
you can do posts that title and it will
render the same way so let's go back to
our route go to this and the first post
title should display there too we have
it displaying twice
I'll probably get rid of the one down
below
pretty great now that we have that set
up why don't we tackle how to say edit a
post so let's go back to our post
controller and to edit we need to
actually have two actions once called
update and one is called edit edit is
the view will actually render and update
is the actual method that will actually
take place so I'll go ahead and create
def update and edit so update we need to
find our post again to know what Tati so
we'll do the same thing as we did for
shell params ID you should do a
server-side check to say hey if the post
has been updated let's redirect the user
to the post itself so we'll do again
post params we're pulling that in from
the bottom here so we're doing that
double verification check if the form
has since updated and then we want to
redirect the user to the post itself so
in this case write that else render edit
great and then for edit we actually just
need to find the post again so post see
how I'm repeating this I'll show you how
later on to make this not so repetitive
great one thing we will need to do which
will get an error for is to actually let
me add to the view first so we can I can
show you by example so let me pull up my
other view on the show page and kind of
walk you through what I did there so
this one we have the page title we have
our section or container and there's
this thing from bulma cult level
class level oops can't spell so on the
left side I'll do pretty much just
follow what I have on like repo left
sign div class level left P class level
item and then this it's just kind of a
placeholder because otherwise the
actions weren't floating to the right
like I wanted so a little behind the
scenes fibbing there right side or where
the actions really will be so these are
going to be like the edit and delete
buttons so we'll do P class level item
again
and inside this we'll have a link to our
actual edit action link to edit we'll
just call it edit and then this will go
edit post path notice it's all dynamic
based on the actual model in mention we
do need to pass the post through to it
though so that's something that's new
and then we can give it a class button
ok and then I'll come back to the delete
one but for now we'll add that
so another link to in fact I'm gonna
leave this I'll just put delete for now
it's not gonna do anything though so I'm
gonna just hard code this but it's a to
do for sure so button is danger
because deletes a little little
complicated on how it works because
there's some data interactivity you need
to take place within the browser
so we'll get to it nav and then I had
just horizontal rule and then we have
our content class again I could have
left that from before but I'll just do
that
so we need our at post content renderer
that okay and later we'll add a section
for comments for now I'm gonna leave
that as is okay so if all goes right we
should be able to edit this post now and
we're missing the template so we
actually need to create that so it'll be
edit HTML TRB and in our case I'm gonna
make this a little more dry and one
thing we absolutely need for sure is
content for and we'll pass in page title
again from the layout and we'll just put
edit post but I also want to since edit
and create kind of use the same form we
might as well make use of the same form
instead of reauthorization and this is
how you do it in rails and I don't have
it created yet but I can
so in posts again in the folder views
folder I'm going to create one make sure
it is underscore at the beginning
that's how rails knows what it is I'm
just gonna title it form that er be HTML
dot RB and if I go back to my
new file when I copy and paste this in I
actually cut it from new paste it in the
form save it and for edit I have render
form already I'm actually gonna copy and
paste this and put it in the new file as
well so we have essentially our partial
and the title for the page in these
views okay so if I always right we
should see our form and the content
within it on this page rails are smart
enough to kind of know that that's an
edit and update kind of scenario so the
data gets fed through so that's pretty
nifty we can probably tweet that button
to say it's probably get rid of this
text actually this will probably be
wrong in the repo but that button text
needs to change dynamically so this
needs to say update post yeah so that's
rails being smart again so I'll just sit
update and it redirects back to the post
so great we have our editing
functionality in place and to test it I
could do a test post content with and
update update there it is and if we go
back to our home page there it is cool
so the last thing to think about is okay
this delete button we need to make sure
that's even possible probably don't want
to always have posts on your site that
you know you can't delete so let's get
back into our post controller and we'll
need one more action called delete or
destroy in this case and we actually we
need to find the post once more
so we'll defined params ID then we could
just put posts not destroy and that's
essentially how it gets deleted but we
actually want to redirect the user to to
the post path so in that case it would
be the index page we can put route route
path there too but I'm gonna do post
path okay so in our view here's where it
gets a little complicated we'll go back
to the show page and that to do I
entered comes into full force now so
I'll actually need to do another link to
and make sure you get the equal sign
okay and then we need to pass in the
post path itself so there's no actual
delete or destroy post path that's not
part of our routes that wouldn't make
sense so we're just getting the posts
path with the post ID and then our
method on it will be delete and it's
typed like this and then you can you
know tap into the browser functionality
and access the confirmation window which
is
typed like so and then I want the Bulma
classes on this as well so we'll do
button and then is danger okay so our
method is the delete method on this post
we're getting its ID and then we're
confirming with the user because you
don't want to just delete it outright
without that kind of gateway in between
so let's verify that that works now so
here's our are you sure and then delete
an hour at our index page with no posts
so let's create another one just to make
sure everything is working second pose
great then it goes to the post cool
third post
great and there they are in line this is
our root path this is our create path or
new path and we go back to the show path
which is getting the ID of the post and
we can edit the post and update the post
and delete it so great that's
essentially the functioning part of the
blog so we've gotten that far
most blogs have common forms though so
we want to actually add that to our view
next and to do that we need to generate
both the controller and a model for
comments so let's go ahead and go back
to rails or NAR I'll actually do get and
finish tation of posts I don't know
posts this is the hardest part I swear
okay cool so we would need to create one
more controller called common controller
I'm gonna actually do rails generate
controller let's just call this comments
and we'll just leave it at that okay and
I'll just do the model too so rails I
mean clean this up rails generate model
let me verify one second one I had
created so yeah we need a model called
comment and its title areas name of the
person commenting would be a string and
the comment would be text I ran into the
weird naming issue that like the comment
thing it kind of gets confusing later on
but I'm gonna keep it as is just so it's
consistent with what you guys will see
but you might change that name to
something different here you'll see what
I mean so let's run that and you can
verify that that migration is in place
and our DB folder again it's a create
comment there it is so we still need to
run migration so rails DB migrate after
you run that should create those tables
there you go okay great
now we can interact with that the first
thing I'm gonna do is go to
our models and this is where relations
comes into play a post is going to have
many comments rails has tons of
documentation on this if you want to
read up on it it's really important to
understand but it's very basic how it
works so that's why I really like it so
if we could do as many comments but a
comments gonna belong to a post
so we'll do belongs to them post notice
this one's singular and this one has
many so that relationship is basically
established just like that so we do have
a comments controller now we should only
really need our create and destroy
methods on this one since it's going to
be showing on the show page of our posts
so let's do a create oops and destroy
and it's a little confusing because we
need to have that you know relationship
between these two models now so we need
to first find our post we need to find
it by the post ID and that's something
we haven't talked about yet is
migrations and one thing that isn't
quite established between these two
models is an ID usually there's a
relationship based on ID between them so
we need to run what's known as a
migration at this point and then we will
do rails generate migration let's see
add post ID two comments so if we run
this hopefully rails are smart enough to
know what we're after but we're taking
the idea of the post and putting a new
table all in the comments model so those
IDs when they're basically you know
related to can have something of
relation so the idea is how that works
it's kind of confusing but we'll see
what happens in our migration here we go
to migrate and our latest one so it
didn't actually sometimes it
automatically does this stuff for you
but unfortunately it didn't so you might
need to add this yourself and the way it
automatically does it is how you type it
but we won't get into that I guess no so
we need to add a column in this case two
comments and then it's going to be post
ID and of the type integer so we'll
close that and we need to run one more
migration so rails DB migrate it should
add that record to our column so now we
have yeah that column comments on
comments which is post ID and it's an
integer
so if all goes right we should be able
to access this as I've typed and we also
need comment to find the comment on the
specific post comments create programs
comment and then we can permit instead
of doing that private function we can
just type it in place like this for the
strong programs that rails needs and we
need to close that and then once that's
good we can redirect to post post okay
so here we're finding the posts based
off of this variable or symbol we
created once we have that we can get the
comments on it and go through that
comments model and then create the new
comment on that post it's kind of kind
of tricky kind of hard to understand but
that's essentially what's happening
so let's first verify that that works
I'm going to go to my show file and I'm
gonna make that form so when we have an
actual comment form here we should be
able to see the name and the field to
type the comment in so let's go to views
layouts post show ok so here's I have
that div from before or that section I
should say I'm gonna go ahead and do a
container when I call this section two
that's part of a spacing thing in bulma
subtitle and just applied various
classes here to kind of design this
without actually doing custom styles and
here we need to add post that comments
that account so you are getting the
posts comments count obviously then we
could just type comments here before I
go on though since this record the
records that we have don't have this
stuff associated with it it's going to
air out if you don't have some of this
stuff like the post ID so I'm going to
go ahead and delete these and then we'll
add fresh ones and I can talk about how
you can do this without the interface
because sometimes rails will throw up an
air screen and you can't access the UI
so I'll show you how to do that it's
called rails console and you can
essentially just interact with your
database through the command line so
next we want to render comments and post
our comments you make some more room you
go and that will essentially be our of
comment feed next is the common form and
I just added a horizontal rule h3 with a
class subtitle and is three just the
sizing class you can put it leave a
reply and then we rendered an actual
form which we still need to create
great so it's going to air out obviously
because we don't have the form we
actually need to create a new post
though so let's do I don't know I think
I'm on my fourth post fourth post
comment and boom Michigan comments form
so we need to create that in our
comments folder let's do a partial
that's a form that HTML ARB and then in
this file it will be using simple form
again and then it gets kind of tricky
here but my grab should we close it so
to make this a little easier I'm going
to grab the content from within this
form and we'll just change the
parameters oops
and this will be named and this will be
comment
okay for save inside the simple form for
we need to pass in both the post and the
post comments let's do post and that
post comments and then this thing called
build and this confused me too but build
I have a definition here it says it
returns one or more new objects of a
collection type that have been in this
Stan she added with the tributes and
linked to this object through a foreign
key so it's kind of how we have the post
ID on the comments we're getting that
post reference from it and then you can
update that form and get that data from
that that thing it says it also only
works if it's associated object that
already exists so it can't be nil so
that's why I deleted those records
because this stuff would air out
otherwise I think that's it for the
forum it's verified that it'll pull
through and then we have post path what
am I missing here alright guys after
quite some time trying to figure this
out I realized immediately when I
thought about it finally a big gotcha is
that to do what we're doing we need to
actually edit our routes file so
comments needs to be within it and I
totally forgot about that so let's let's
go back to that and actually fast
forward it and try to do some more code
here for the destroy method to see if I
just had something wrong I'm gonna
delete that for now and then we'll we'll
get it in the next part after I get this
crap working so let's fix that and then
I'm gonna go into my rounds file in
config close these comments are nested
within the scope of posts we actually
need to create a block with Ruby here
and do
and and then inside here will do
resources for comments this is only for
nested kind of things most cases you'll
if you're having completely new routes
you'll do just similar like we did the
resources posts but in this case we're
doing it this way so since we edited our
routes file I'm gonna go ahead and
restart my server cleared out of it here
and we have it running do control C and
then up arrow side rails s again so now
if we do actually I'll stay on that view
and go over to this here and I'm gonna
do rake routes this just show you what I
mean
so since they're nested you'll notice
how it works
it goes posts and then the ID and then
comments and there's no just immediate
comment route so when they're nested
like that that's how that works
pretty simple okay so let's go back to
our code editor and actually have the
demo app that I had built previously up
try she's trying to troubleshoot and
let's go back to our comments file on
our app views and actually the post show
files when I'm after I have that render
comments form showing so we should be
able to at this point see that form up
here so yes it took me too long to
figure that out and I feel bad for it
but anyway with our controller setup and
our data models you know related we can
now leave a reply I'm gonna go just put
any limerence this is my first comment
leave it and we're missing a partial
that is what the comment would spit out
as so it's kind of like the show view of
our comment that will render once that
happens right here to get that we
actually need to create a new file
called comment but I'm gonna make it up
partial so underscore comments HTML and
I near me and I'll reference another
file I created from before and this one
I'm going to use a box class from bulma
and inside that will be an article and
it's going to have a class of media and
will have a class of media content if
you don't emit installed that's how I'm
doing this dot notation really recommend
it on whatever code editor you use kind
of a lifesaver so you could just do P
and strong inside that will have the
comment name
and I'm gonna actually put : and then
the comment itself and here's where I
mentioned naming convention before and
this is why it's a bad one because I'm
referencing the comment model with the
comment data type so it's confusing as
as hell right there so definitely maybe
use like something different than me if
you're just following along but for
learning purposes it's not a huge deal
but just know naming conventions are
huge and if we want to delete this it's
very similar to the one we did on the
post so I'm going to go ahead and type
this one out do a link to delete the
only difference here is we're
referencing that post again so we need
this bracket notation and then also the
comment ID to make sure we're
referencing the right record
so we'll do a method of delete and then
a class again button is danger oops
danger and then we actually need this
data confirm in window again this is
just essentially hacking a browser and
there are ways to work around this say
you want to use a different modal to ask
this are you sure kind of question you
can do that that's something I won't be
touching on in this video series but
it's it's a workaround you need some
JavaScript to kind of tie in to the the
whole structure but you gonna
essentially like say use a bootstrap
modal or even involvement in this case
to do this all right so with our comment
parcel posted we should be able to
render this comment now those comments
missing comment builder hmm why is that
oh it's I've written I think I named it
comments yeah it should be comment sorry
guys so make that singular save and
kaboom alright so there's the comment we
have a delete button it doesn't do
anything in it does this data thing but
it actually won't go back to the server
and say hey actually delete this so we
need to actually create that next but
essentially hey comments are working so
that's cool to do that delete method
will need to go back to our controller
our comments controller and we have that
destroy method I mean
and here again we need to access the
post find it I should say so we do post
find params and we need it by the post
ID since we're in the commons controller
so through the comments we are finding
the post associated with it
if that makes sense and then we need to
also find the comment to destroy so post
our comments dot find and then the
params of the specific comment so it's
just basically the ID of it and then
we'll actually destroy it and will
redirect the user to the post paths and
this actually needs to feed that post
symbol in so we know which one to go to
and that should be it for the destroy so
let's make sure that works well refresh
this delete this are you sure yeah great
so we're still back on this post and
it's all working you'll notice that the
URL has eight I've added in the leader
records just trying to troubleshoot
along the way so you might notice that
that happens to you to do that
realistically you sometimes your
interface goes to the error screen so if
you wanted to say do that from the
command line which is probably the way
you should
you can do this thing called rails
console and this there's a ton of
documentation on it but you're
essentially running a Ruby command line
that's embedded within the terminal in
rails so we can access our post model if
we want so say I'm just creating a
variable here if posts equals post it'll
actually ask you to do this weird
connection thing so just do that and
forget about what it does because it's
quite easy but clear that and then you
have posts and then just say post all
and you can see all the posts on your
current model and here's our the one
that was showing it's posted with an ID
of eight it shows me in the title and
the content so if you want to actually
manage this stuff you can do post I
don't know done equals post dot find
eight since that's the ID there and
it'll come back with that same one if we
wanted a post dot since we assigned it
to that post we now just have that post
handy as the variable here
it keeps outputting I want to update
that title so let's say post dot title
and then we'll do an equal sign this is
post updated from rails console then it
spits it back you still need to save it
so I'm going to remember to do that so
post out save there you go and then if
we now get back if you want to just exit
this you can go exit so if we navigate
back to this post it updated so that's
essentially a way to interact with your
database without having to like do any
crazy UI stuff I think it's the pattern
that most developers go with simply
because it's straightforward and you can
actually sit without any errors so
you'll notice right now there's no user
accounts or anything like that any user
can access this blog and delete it and
edit it that's not very secure in a
future video I'll probably talk more
about user accounts how to
those and make sure certain users can
only have read-only access and other
users can have writing access and
deleting editing all that stuff one more
thing for I forget on the controller I
mentioned how we repeated a lot of stuff
and this line in particular we repeat
here on the show we don't update on edit
and destroy we can create another
private definition here so we'll call it
actually fine post for instance and
essentially just keep that line in there
so I'll just copy and paste it
oops great so it's there now and we have
access to it basically for all of these
methods and actions so rails has just
hey anything called before action that
you can initialize before anything
happens on your app so we can just
define it as before action and grab that
method and then on it we can only queue
it in for an array of these actions so
for instance I only need it on show
update oops
update edit and destroy so what that
does is essentially means I don't need
it
now for let's see edit and show show can
just be empty update
if they can get rid of that line edit I
can leave it empty and destroy so that
really cleans up our code it almost
makes it look like it shouldn't even
work but it does and it's awesome so we
have that available to us you can do
before actions for other things like
authentication you can even do things
such as making sure your app is secure
like when you do enter certain criteria
on your model you can actually tell it
that it should validate in some way
based on the server response I'll get
into more of that as we go on but that's
essentially without any security right
now we have a working blog with comments
hope you guys enjoyed this if you're
just getting into Ruby on Rails I am as
well so don't consider me a pro but I've
certainly you studied up on it I've been
building an side project on the side
using it and I figured I'd share the
wealth and try to teach others so I can
better learn myself so more is to come I
hope you enjoyed this again and thanks
for watching